clear blue skies out there it is
beautiful this morning as we look out
over the southwest valley
and gorgeous temperatures we're in the
60s and some low 70s around the valley
not much in the way of humidity and
winds are pretty light to calm
we do have some 60s the lake's at 66
summerlin's at 68 69 in green valley
this morning
nellis coming in at 65 still low 70s on
the strip in downtown so we're heading
for
a pretty toasty memorial day weekend not
unusual for us here
in las vegas and southern nevada keep
plenty of cool water around we're going
to be in those upper 90s
through the weekend and might even hit
100 for memorial day we'll see
if not we're looking at our first triple
digit days of the year
to start off june next week cold front
bringing some rain into the pacific
northwest
but all of those high clouds from
yesterday they were gone by five o'clock
we made it to about 94 yesterday we're
looking for about 96
today and then the numbers just keep
going up as we get through the weekend
to finish off the month of may
99 by sunday we'll have a few high
clouds around on saturday but look at
memorial day
we're looking at probably 100 we'll be
very very close
and if not then then when yup june 101
tuesday 104
on wednesday 103 thursday ouch